yeah so on an average day you know i'll
either wake up super early because i'm
working on a pitch or writing down ideas
or writing a treatment for a show or
going to the office with the guys um or
i wake up at noon i roll out of bed i
spend about 15 minutes scratching
randomly we'll just see what
see what's feeling you know you never
know how the body's going to react then
i go to some hot room yoga
then i go back home and i just pull open
a chrome browser incognito and just
start with the usuals i'll hit a pink
lab a huge is
a red tube a fantastic cc uh
pornhub you porn a green cactus next
dot xx hamster snuff
snuff [ __ ] nurse enough philosophical
snuffin meisters
um there's a lot of snuff
it's a whole lot
this is ed carrasco from nmr magazine
and i'm here with the awesome kevin
pereira
of player versus pain
yeah there we go there we go
just take just let it ride let it ride
as long as you guys want to
as long as you guys want to i'm here on
the last one clapping
player versus pain is a an awesome new
web series that super creative is doing
with machinima
it's very simple concept two gamers
playing a video game against each other
while being tortured i don't know what
this is the gamers they're playing and
then i don't know how to do the torque
that is not that's not appropriate since
for that i don't know how to do the
torture with my hands but the thing is
they're playing video games while being
tortured so what does that mean that
means
we've got guys on waxing tables playing
tetris and when someone clears five
lines
they lose a tetris shaped strip out of
their hairy backs and or thighs or asses
well actually all of the guys at super
creative we actually met at an s
m dungeon in downtown los angeles and so
right away we knew that okay we love
flogs we love
paddles we love leather we love studs
how can we get someone else to pay
for us to wear this gear and to hit each
other with it and so we came to
machinima we pitched them on the idea
turns out they're crazy freaks as well
and so lo and behold
we're now doing torturous things so
waxing was a no-brainer gamers are a
pretty hairy sort
um you know the the the the wii tennis
with tennis ball launchers firing 80
mile an hour tennis balls at your
genitals
that was just random inspiration um
the being flogged while playing mortal
kombat and shocked with callers again
that harkens
back to our days of meeting in cd clubs
um i think the one that
that surprised us the most was the
paintball while playing halo we had two
gamers
playing halo deathmatch against each
other and professional
paintball rifle guys behind the cameras
and they would just
unload every time you got killed in the
game and of all the torches i mean
people get shot with paintballs every
day they do it for sport
they do it for fun but this was the only
torture that ended up with people on the
ground
huddled over themselves crying actually
in pain
um there's a great moment where these uh
two uh
very attractive female gamers were
playing uh rock band against each other
you had me at hello right like i'll
watch that web video i don't care what
it is there's two gorgeous women playing
rock band however
we decided to up the ante and we put
electro stim pads on their arms
and on some of their legs at times and
so we would shock them it's that thing
in
therapy that will make your your arm
sort of quake a little bit
and uh yeah and so they were getting
shocked so hard that they were dropping
the rock band controllers and every time
they'd miss
a serious note or they dropped their
controller a dominatrix would be behind
them
hitting them with a paddle or flogging
them and so afterwards
they were just covered in i mean they
look like courtney love
from the waist down it was just welts
and bruises and sadness
it was amazing everything you love about
video games kill shots
special moves
and co-op play
it's all right here time for some
unfriendly competition
player versus pain this
is gonna hurt only
on the [ __ ] of a prize all kidding aside
the torture aspect of the show
while our gamers are experiencing pain
um
most of them actually enjoyed it and
that doesn't mean that they're
masochistic by any stretch i mean they
were just
they were sort of in it to prove that
they could take that punishment you know
and there was this playful
one-upsmanship
between each other but we were very very
safe we had emts on site
everything was tested thoroughly we knew
that uh nobody should be putting any
undue
unnecessary harm like i said the only
punishment where someone was
actually really really hurt or i think
experienced any real
real pain was when they took a paintball
to a very sensitive region
uh during halo so um thankfully
lawsuits pending everybody had a good
time
smiles and laughs nobody got hurt nobody
um you know machinima is killing it the
the the days of
iptv the the whole notion that there's
television and then there's internet
those are those are gone i mean they're
they're quickly blurring and in five to
seven years even your grandparents won't
know
how their content is making it up making
it to whatever screen they're watching
and so machinima is on the forefront of
that i mean they've got so many channels
they're diversified they're edgy they're
willing to take risks
uh they have budgets that's amazing in
the web world
you know normally it's you want to make
a show great here's a flip cam and uh
here's a a light off my grandmother's
nightstand have fun
but they really get ideas they champion
them they encourage it they like people
to push things toward towards the edge
and
with a series like player versus pain
you have to be edgy you can't half-ass
it
i you know i'm very fortunate to have a
really awesome and motivated fan base
from attack of the show
um and they're a very specific fan base
which is why i was so excited to do
player versus paint i think a lot of the
guys that
that love that content from attack and
the the women as well they're going to
gravitate towards what we're doing
with player versus pain but um it's been
a weird journey since leaving attack we
uh super creative we did a show for
sci-fi called viral video showdown
where youtubers competed against each
other and i somehow tripped and fell
into the awesome gig of hosting
a game show for telepictures called
let's ask america which is
on one end of the spectrum there's the s
m and the torture of player versus pain
on the other end of the spectrum there's
me uh speaking to housewives in
cincinnati
hosting a game show and so i've been
sort of straddling both worlds for the
last few months and it's
really fascinating to watch new twitter
followers come in
and new facebook page requests come in
from like you know
moms with soccer vans that are prepping
capri suns for their kids after the big
game
and dudes who are like yeah man shock
her more and
uh you know pull her pants down just a
little i mean i mean whatever it is
i have the dichotomy i have the spectrum
of fans and it's
been like a real blast to be able to
cater to both sides of that
inspiration can come from anywhere and
that's truly like it
for inspiration for anything to come
from anywhere you know and
and the the beauty of of working with
super creative and coming up with
properties is that we
we sit around and if we find ourselves
in the middle of having a good time
or really enjoying something whether
it's a discussion or an experience
we then take a step back and go okay
wait a minute if we're enjoying this so
much
will other people okay if other people
will then what's the best way to present
this experience to somebody
can we make a series out of it can we
make a web series out of it you know the
other day at the driving range
uh you're not supposed to admit to this
when you're in the driving range but
when the little guy comes out in the
cart to pick up all the golf balls that
have been hit
everybody it's like the unspoken thing
but everybody there is hoping to hit
that [ __ ]
it's the best thing in the world right
you got a moving target he's used to it
he's got his earbuds in he's fine but
when you hear that golf ball hit off
that metal cage
there's a little bit of satisfaction
right a couple droplets a year and come
out everybody gets excited we're all on
the same page here but no one talks
about it
and we said if this is the moment that
we live for at the driving range how can
we turn this into something and we
started coming up with the idea of
turning a driving range into a shooting
gallery
with big moving targets and you know
metal things and glasses that you can
break and
you know things that you can shatter and
give people points and let people spin
those points
who knows it will ever become a series
or a show or whatever but that's an
example of
being in the moment having so much fun
and realizing oh this is a fun thing how
can we take this to the next level
how can we make this a game or make it
something that's enjoyable for other
people to watch
i i got started because i i ran an
internet service provider so
um you know back in the day of dial up
internet i know some people still dial
up so maybe someone's watching this now
on aol or earthlink or whatever but
um we created an internet provider
because there wasn't one
in northern california and so me and my
business partner
we started it grew up to a few thousand
customers and we had all this bandwidth
and bandwidth at the time was really
expensive servers were expensive doing
video like this
was really cost prohibitive it really
required some some resources well we had
them
so what i did was i sat down and i was
like okay i've got these servers i've
got this bandwidth what can i do with it
and real audio had just come out with a
an encoder that lets you encode your
voice and then eventually they came to
videos so i launched
a daily web series it was called
pointless audio uh
grew into pointless video or pointless
television and every day i did a show
sometimes live
uh you know 10 to 20 minutes a day we
took callers
we did interviews i talked about games i
reviewed
gadgets i gave tutorials on how to hack
people
on how to you know break into their
email or crash their instant messenger
or their icq
it was really really random stuff they
did prank phone calls
most of it still exists somewhere on the
internet the majority of it is
incredibly embarrassing
but um that's what i did when i was
probably about 13 or 14 and that grew
into
everything that i'm doing today and you
still do some you still do something
similar to pointless uh
yeah i recently launched uh you know the
world needed another podcast
i was listening to the cries there
weren't enough podcasts
so i decided to do one as well and i
remember i was sitting down
uh at the studio and they're like so
what are we gonna call this thing we
were about to go live we didn't have a
name we certainly didn't have a logo we
had nothing we're just gonna sit down
and chat and i was like well the use the
old one used to be called pointless
audio
this has video let's just call it
pointless and now that has grown into a
thing now that is
you can grab it on itunes and grab it on
stitcher and watch it on youtube but
i'm having a blast with it you know it's
really fun to just sit down and have
conversations with people
hey everybody this is kevin pereira i'm
the founder of super creative please
check us out at supercreative.tv you can
also check out player versus pain
over at machinima dot com and to read
the full interview and to see the photo
shoot and all the madness that happened
here today
check out newmediarockstars.com also
fantastic.cc
pull it up do it incognito make sure the
parents are at the grocery store